Michael W Kaufman is a political
historian and a graduate of the
University of Virginia he has studied
the Lincoln assassination for more than
30 years in his efforts he researched
this book he has not only gone through
firsthand material he lived in John
Wilkes Booth's house and he traced part
of his escape route as first-hand
experience he has appeared on A&E the
History Channel c-span and The Learning
Channel and was called to testify as an
expert witness in the 1995 booth
excavation hearings and he now lives in
Southern Maryland so would you please
join me in welcoming Michael Kaufman
Thank You Allison and thank you Sam I've
never never had a stunt post before I'm
not sure what that means but let's be on
the lookout for a 12-foot leap sometime
during my talk well I take it you're all
interested to some degree in the
assassination of Abraham Lincoln and
there must be some reason for that an
event that occurred so long ago can
still hold a great deal of fascination
for so many people and as you gathered
from the introduction that has held my
interest since early childhood actually
I've been wanting to write a book for so
many years and I began I guess about 35
years ago in my own childish way as a
young teenager writing what turned out
to be a very very bad effort at writing
something but it was a couple hundred
pages and as soon as I got to the end I
started reading it back again from the
beginning and I realized just how bad it
was so I locked that away vowed that I
destroy it someday and write something
much better and I've been working until
last year to do just that
the reason this story holds such a
fascination for me is in part because of
something that that the general public
doesn't really seem to hasn't hasn't
quite caught on to the fact that it has
been so little covered over the years
and there is so many so much room for
finding new discoveries even as a
teenager when I first came to Washington
on a research trip and went over to
Ford's Theater I started finding things
that filled in the gaps of all the books
that I'd already read now if that seems
a little bit surprising to you keep in
mind that during all the the intervening
years I have belonged to an informal
group of people we called ourselves the
booth buffs and I see a few of them here
today a great many of them were retired
government workers who simply took on
this is what I called catching the bug
and that is once you take an interest in
the subject you just kind of keep going
and going and going
I read Jim bishops book the day Lincoln
was shot it's a great many people read
that and were captured by the the drama
of the book the way that he wrote that
story was just so compelling that I felt
right away as a young teenager that I
knew the whole story and I sort of felt
that I owned it and I don't know whether
it's just that case or whether it's the
way Jim Bishop wrote it but whatever it
was I was hooked and I came to
Washington because I was living in
California and finding it very hard to
get close enough to the sources I could
buy the micro films anybody anybody can
but there's so many unanswered questions
in those official documents and you have
to go into other areas and other kinds
of documents to find and he just found
it very hard to do that by remote
control so I came to Washington and took
a job with the FBI which is almost right
across the street and every night after
work I would come over here and they'd
throw me out at closing time
and this went on for a couple of years
and I sort of wormed my way over to the
Library of Congress and started going
through the manuscripts over there and I
found very quickly that the story
embedded in those records that the
prosecutors had gathered in 1865 really
wasn't the same
thing that you were seeing in all the
books you see the books if you go back
and trace the original sources of
everything those books are written from
magazine articles and newspaper articles
and things that came out over the course
of 70 80 even 90 years by the people who
said gee you know this is the
anniversary of Abraham Lincoln's death
in our fair little city we have two
citizens who were there on that day and
this is what they remember well you know
what by 1945 or whatever those people
don't remember what planet they're on
but who is going to say to them you know
you've got the story wrong you've got
the details wrong and so in part maybe
to humor them in part maybe to to pay
homage to those who really touched the
face of history those who are actually
there we want to know what they said
it's fascinating even if maybe their
memory isn't so good anymore
well when I started to go through the
original records I saw such a huge
difference between those records that
were locked away from 1865 till about
1940 when people started getting more
large-scale access to them here in the
National Archives and I get the feeling
that authors were not really that
comfortable with the new story that was
in those records because when they
started looking through I could tell
that there were things they saw in there
that didn't didn't quite match the
record that had been out there and sayd
try and massage things and get the two
of them to work together and sometimes
it was a little bit awkward I finally
decided that what I would do is stick
with the original records and tell
everybody right up front look this is
not what you've read before and this is
why it's not what you read before the
whole time I was doing this I was going
systematically through these records
going from real one of microcopy $5.99
through real 16 of it going through the
the trial transcripts of the conspiracy
trial and so forth from page one
to volume three and so on and I could do
this in part because I knew so well the
way my compatriots in the booth Bluffs
were working and they were doing it a
little differently James O Hall for
example a dear friend of mine had been
tackling questions one at a time when
somebody would bring up a question or
when something would occurred to him he
would he would attack it like a pitbull
and just hang on it until he got all the
answers he wanted out of it if that
meant consulting researches in England
or or in Georgia or wherever it was he
would find all the answers to that John
Brennan a dear friend I see a few smiles
over there John Brennan was sort of the
hub of our group and I kid you not he
wrote me letters once twice three times
a day for more than 20 years with the
things passing on information that other
people in our group had found or sort of
ruminating on what do you think this
means or that means and so forth now his
letters were not boring they would
always come dressed up a little bit in
an envelope that was marked something
like Michael Kaufman regional
distributor of Surat brand saran-wrapped
rattraps
or something like that I mean they were
amusing he was a great writer he was a
funny man and you know rest his soul he
passed away in 96 but we miss him dearly
and he's the one more than anybody else
who really kept me going on this because
he had something new and interesting
around every corner well to make a long
story short because of all these things
coming out we were finding out new
information about the assassination not
always big but sometimes enormous we'd
find out something new every single day
and we were so absorbed that we were you
know we were government workers we were
we were young maybe some of us couldn't
write very well whatever the problem was
we did not have any publishing clout and
so at a completely different level while
in the trenches learning all this stuff
the publishing industry is going along
with its you know high high profile
writers digging out story after story
about booths or whatever and it would
always come out in some ways at least to
us it would always come out to be pretty
much the same from one book to the next
to the next and it was always a little
bit frustrating but I always vowed that
someday I was going to break through
that and I was going to make myself
enough of a writer that I could get into
that and bring that story alive to a
general audience and write a book that
people would respect and would want to
pass around among themselves I wanted to
be the new Jim Bishop that's how I put
it - Random House when when I first took
an interest in getting this book
contract and I said you know that book
was written the day Lincoln was shot was
written the year before I was born it's
hardly ever been out of print and when I
give the John Wilkes Booth escape route
tours the bus tours people come up to me
all the time and say I'm interested
today because I read that book that's
what I want to be and I said that all
along and this has been the goal in
writing this book well because I was
interested in getting kind of a new
paradigm going I wanted to be the the
new person on the block
the person who established the story
that the general public would start to
to start to see as the as the genuine
truth I decided I'd have to I'd have to
come up with more than just the ordinary
run-of-the-mill narrative I'd have to
come up with new ideas I'd have to come
up with new information and more than
anything else I had to make the story
come alive and in order to do that I
started looking into the people because
I believe as so many others do that
history is really collective biography
and that what drives history is what
drives people so I went
through all the different accounts I
could find of the people who were in
Ford's Theater the night of the
assassination I found about 350 of them
and I tried tracking down their
descendants to see if they had you know
family letters anything like that and
it's amazing I was able to find quite a
few things and had the things that the
people wrote when they wrote home that
night in some cases really amazed me
because they said things that I hadn't
seen before and they said things that I
wouldn't have thought of one man for
example a man who had had earned a
Congressional Medal of Honor he said I
was I was sitting there and I saw this
whole thing take take place right in
front of my eyes and as he went out the
back door and we suddenly realized what
had happened I thought to myself oh and
here I sit fully armed with two pistols
and I did nothing you kind of imagine
yourself now add to that the agony of
all this happening in front of your wife
or girlfriend you know and the sort of
macho culture that was prevalent and you
you add embarrassment to the mix you
know you kind of kind of try to try to
see people and and how they react to
things and and and how their feelings
and their thoughts drove the story I
thought that would distinguish the book
I and sort of make it a little bit
different from what you generally saw
here and there and and from the comments
that that I've gotten back afterwards I
I think that generally has worked in all
I've collected little biographies and
genealogies of about 2,800 people all
together obviously couldn't put those in
one book but but it's been fun because
there have been some real interesting
characters sometimes you can't put them
in the book for example Fe German a
woman who had been a prominent actress
in her day a woman whose photograph was
found on John Wilkes Booth at the time
of his death the only person to write a
letter of condolence to the booth family
a very nice and decent and sweet young
woman who at the time of the
assassination I learned from her family
happened to be posing for her
brother-in-law Constantine Brumidi as he
was painting the inside of the Capitol
dome and the same face that is on that
picture that was found in booths body is
also at the right hand of George
Washington inside the Capitol dome on
the left hand is her sister Lola and the
two of them as you look up there I just
I just can't help but smirk a little bit
knowing who they were and that the
artist himself used his his wife and
sister-in-law for these allegorical
figures when I think of Effie it brings
to mind the fact that she was one of the
people employed by booth in his very
brief career as a theater manager in
1863 booth rented out the Washington
Theatre in the city of Washington right
down the street from here
and he he hired a number of people who
had been working at Ford's Theatre I
know this because I own some play bills
and things from it any when you look at
the cast list and you look at at the
cast list at Ford's Theatre before and
after you notice that there's some of
the same people why did they not
continue working at Ford's Theater he
didn't he didn't rob them he hired them
because they were out of work he started
this theater in part because Ford's
Theater had burned down and had not yet
been rebuilt and so the stagehands the
people who worked for John Ford had been
unemployed for some months John Wilkes
came into town and he rented this
theater and hired these people and gave
them some work for a couple of weeks it
is I believe because of that that a few
years later when he came in or a year
and a half later when he came into
Washington and started hanging out at
Ford's Theater some of those people felt
in some way obligated to him
to do favors to feed his horse to keep
care of the stable and the the key to
the stable and so on and he was able to
to get them to do things which in at
least one case nearly cost a man his
life but it explains in part what John
Wilkes Booth did what kind of person he
was to get people beholden to him and
Booth himself was really the key to the
story his interactions with people very
very important but all of this sprang
from this a little bit about Fe German
the actress now there are so many people
connected to this story that is
fascinating was one of these one of
these people who had been hauled in as a
suspect in the assassination really had
nothing to do with it but but he was a
certainly a very odd character and of
course they let him go and eventually he
went on to England where he became
Scotland Yard's prime suspect bless you
know he became Scotland Yard's prime
suspect in the Jack the Ripper killings
later on you hear things about George
Washington Gale in all the books you see
only his name if that he was a man who
was hauled in as a result of his placing
an ad in a Selma Alabama newspaper the
year before offering a million dollars
for the assassination of Lincoln just a
name right when you look into it it's
maybe a little bit more interesting the
fact that he used to be a federal
prosecutor so he should have known
better little stories like that people
just I've absolutely fascinated by all
the people who come in and out of this
story and I've always thought it was a
shame that none of this ever made its
way into print and I must tell you
III got slapped down a few times in
writing this book about all the people
I'm trying to cram in here but you know
what yeah I think it came out okay but
there are so many people connected to
this story
and Anna and I felt the more of them
that I can put in the more human I was
able to make this story I was very
surprised when one person after another
after another in the whole process of
getting a book started they would all
say to me hasn't this been written to
death already I mean really is there
room for another book and when they
asked me that at Random House I thought
well it's sort of a pro forma question
I'm sure they asked all the author's is
they will just want to see you know but
no actually this is what almost
everybody believes that that this story
has just been beaten into the earth and
having having been in sort of in that
cocoon of the the booth buffs for years
and seeing just how much is still out
there every every time you turn the
corner you bump into something new art
knows this I I was just astounded that
the people really believed that that
it's all been covered by now if you take
the conspiracy for example there's never
been a single book anywhere that
mentions the Roman Hotel the Roman hotel
is where booth and the conspirators met
almost on a daily basis is that that's
located over where you know forgive me
I'm one of those cynical media types
have been in the news media you know the
court how the federal courthouse is over
there which you know in my day was to
call that the Hinkley Beach because the
Hinkley trial was was taking place there
and during the summer but as it's right
over by there on on Pennsylvania Avenue
I'm sorry that direction
I lost my bearings by the way this
magnificent renovation of this building
I going through this you know maze of
new facilities and and beautiful shiny
new rooms and I'm very impressed by this
but anyway but I does it does cause me
to lose my my direction a little bit
anyway you don't see even the most basic
things frankly and the question that I
wanted to answer I really don't think I
don't I don't see any evidence that
anybody had ever asked this question
before when they wrote their books did
somebody ask honestly why did booth say
he was killing the president
he said beforehand he said during and he
said after that he felt Lincoln was a
tyrant okay my my intuition tells me
okay check that out is that sane is that
rational
why would somebody think Lincoln is a
tyrant and that led me into the
constitutional issues and the whole
political scene in Washington which then
sort of focused down on Southern
Maryland in particular and that's
fascinating I don't think that's covered
anywhere near enough in civil war
literature and the kinds of things that
people were saying in editorials not
only throughout the United States but in
England and Canada and other places you
can simply go through day by day where
booth was it's not that hard to do
because he was an actor and because you
know he's going to the this theater and
that theater and it would always appear
in the newspapers there's a man named
art Luke's who did a magnificent job of
checking down checking out all of booths
theatrical performances over the years
and a big thick book that he came up
with only 12 copies in print but at any
rate we know where booth was at all
times and what I did was went through
the newspapers in all of those cities to
see what they're saying about Abraham
Lincoln and it's amazing they talked
about how this senator or that senator
says Abraham Lincoln is acting like
Caesar it's just too bad we don't have a
Brutus now that kind of thing really
resonated with John Wilkes Booth the son
of Junius Brutus booth because
generation after generation the booth
family had always believed the way to
deal with the tyrant is to kill him and
when booth said Sic Semper Tyrannis
he was repeating the words on the bottom
of the seal of Virginia the rest of the
seal shows virtus standing there over
the slain tyrant his crown fallen on the
ground this is the good thing in the
booth family philosophy one generation
after another had believed not only that
you kill a tyrant but that you fight him
with everything you've got and John
Wilkes Booth wanted most of all to be a
booth
his father was a very distinguished
actor who unfortunately after making his
name first in England and then in the
United States was exposed as a bigamist
he had left England and his wife and
young child there to start a new family
in America when the first wife came to
America after hearing that her husband
was very successful in the United States
she ran around questioning the
legitimacy and the identity of all those
little kids 10 of them including John
Wilkes and this led John Wilkes Booth I
believe to do everything he could to
prove perhaps to himself but certainly
to the rest of the world that he really
was the the heir to that genius that so
many people admired he tattooed his
initials jwb on the back of one hand he
became an actor just like his father he
adopted the family politics and so on
and and this is one of the things I
think that psychologically was going on
in booths head from childhood
onward so there's the collision course
there it comes
Abraham Lincoln from the very beginning
of the war sees that Maryland Booth's
home state can be the gatekeeper
when Lincoln called for troops in April
1861 he found that those troops because
of the way the railroads were they had
to come more or less through Baltimore
and people were so state oriented as
opposed to national oriented in those
days that the visit of troops from
Pennsylvania or Massachusetts was
regarded by some people as a foreign
invasion on the 19th of April there was
the riot and Lincoln decided we can't
let this happen we cannot let Maryland
sea seed from the Union that would leave
the federal capital deep inside enemy
territory
so what Lincoln did was declared martial
law first and what I call the i-95
corridor I suspect he didn't call it
that but then it spread throughout
Maryland and then throughout the United
States and any place under Lincoln's
control and people could be arrested for
anything or for nothing at all and
that's where the charge of tyrant came
from it stayed throughout the war a
number of members of the Maryland
legislature were arrested in the middle
of the night and carried off to prison
though they hadn't done anything and the
the presses were smashed up or shut down
the newspapers shut down those allowed
to remain in business were censored they
always had a federal officer right there
in the premises to keep an eye on what
they said now we all know why Lincoln
did this I believe he wanted this to be
one nation he wanted to keep the Union
as one and he never wavered from that
purpose and all the criticism that he
took for going to this extraordinary
step was probably matched on the other
side by people who said he hadn't done
enough and that you you really have to
look at the opposition you have to look
at where booth and people like booth
come from to appreciate the situation
Lincoln was in because Lincoln was torn
from both sides and all things
considered he did an absolutely
remarkable job of weaving his way
through these very bitter very violent
and deadly political
groups that is again I think another
another thing you can learn from
studying the assassination you start
with booth and you work your way out and
lo and behold there's this opposition
movement against Lincoln that that most
people really don't play up very much
certainly after the assassination it
would have been in poor taste to do that
well so you go to the plot and you find
all kinds of things you didn't know I
like to put everything in a computer
database and because I knew nothing
about computer databases I did it all
wrong and it worked out beautifully the
reason I say wrong is because you know
historians generally will put something
in a computer database so they can get
statistical data you know age versus you
know median income and all that sort of
thing on this block or that block I
don't know at all that all I know is
that I started typing the records eleven
thousand pages I started going through
and typing a synopsis of each little
event into this database where did this
happen when did it happen
you know what are the keywords or some
little codes and all this and I could I
could sort these things out in
chronological order and I was able to
find a lot of things live they were a
little cause and effect subplots
I also found was I thought was pretty
interesting was a an event that took
place on the 18th of March 1865 when
John Surratt and George Atzerodt two of
the conspirators went down to Mary
Surratt's Tavern in surrattsville now
Clinton and they were going to hide some
guns because they had just failed in a
so-called attempt to capture Lincoln and
they wanted to put the guns down there
so they they'd have them ready in case
they they tried again they met a man
named David Herold again one of the
conspirators and Herold had the guns and
said okay well you know we can't leave
them anywhere else
jeonse rats is here I know a hiding
place they go into the tavern and they
put the guns in the tavern but not until
the two federal detectives they're left
they had run into these detectives one
of which happened to be the brother of
one of the conspirators John Atzerodt
whose brother George they were a split
family as so many Maryland families were
John was a unionist and a federal
detective George was a blockade runner
rebel secessionist sympathizer and a
conspirator against Lincoln and when the
two of them ran into each other just by
happenstance at the Mary Surratt tavern
they talked and they had a brew and they
just you know talked over old times I
hadn't seen each other in a while and
and then John got up and left and went
back to Baltimore whereupon George went
back to his little conspiracy business
and both of them well excuse me and John
went to his grave never knowing what had
been transpiring at that moment that he
had stumbled upon this very important
milestone in the booth conspiracy he
never knew that but when I studied that
like everything else and you can tell
this by my speaking style by the way
like everything else it reminds me of
something and that reminded me of the at
Surratt family being split when George
Atzerodt was eventually convicted and
hanged for his part in the conspiracy
all hangings under federal authority had
to be overseen by a United States
Marshal and the marshal who got the
short straw that day was at Sarat
brother-in-law John Smith now can you
imagine the conversation as he came home
that night hi honey how was your day
just one glaring example of the
gut-wrenching
unimaginable emotions that must have
gone through so many households during
the Civil War everything reminds me a
story everybody you know everything
reminds me of people but sooner or later
it kind of comes down to facts too and
when I looked at all the books on the
assassination I thought it was a little
bit peculiar that there's been so much
attention given to the trial of the
conspirators but there's never really
been a full treatment of it in fact
there have been a number of different
transcripts published of the trial but
they're either paraphrased or or you
know the official government version was
just paraphrased and that's kind of what
would be the point of that there's
another one that's completely that just
cut off like about four-fifths of the
way in and you know for no apparent
reason
it just stopped reporting eventually I
ended up typing from the the longhand
notes I ended up typing the whole thing
all over again from scratch and the
reason I wanted to do that is because I
was afraid I'd missed something and sure
enough there were things in there that
just amazed me the little things that
went on behind the scenes - that were
not in the transcripts were also
fascinating the Library of Congress has
the Joseph Holt Papers and when you look
in there you see that one of the
reporters after hearing all this
business about top security and what it
takes to get a pass to get into the
courtroom which started by the way the
the trial started in secret so these
were these were primo items you couldn't
just walk into this courtroom and after
all the security measures that were
taken it's really surprised me that a
gustas Katherine was allowed in because
Katherine had been working for one of
the Washington newspapers the man who
was kind of a self-appointed
chief reporter of the trial Ben Pittman
looked over at Katherine on the first
day of the trial and he says well that
scoundrel he can't be in here
and he went over and told the Secretary
of War did you know that not only is
this guy a rebel but also he had been in
Cincinnati where Pittman was from and
had been convicted and done a couple
years in prison for some sort of larceny
or something and then you know he as
soon as he got back out again he set
himself up as the you know guardian of
some orphanage or something like that
and ran off with all the proceeds where
he went down to Memphis where they
couldn't catch him was still in rebel
hands and started a secessionist
newspaper now this is a guy they led
into the trial and of course they they
immediately had to get rid of Augustus
kazran but none of this has ever been
reported anywhere no trial transcript
ever mentions the the things that went
on behind the scenes that I think are
absolutely fascinating no trial
transcript mentions for example that the
doctors who were brought in to examine
one of the conspirators man named Lewis
Powell and I should explain that Powell
had been I think booth closest you know
lieutenant and all of this Powell had
been assigned to assassinate Secretary
of State William Seward and he failed at
this miserably barely got away and when
he was finally captured at Mary
Surratt's house which didn't make her
look very good he was brought in and and
prosecuted and because his behavior was
so strange and he seemed so stoic and
because he was constipated they thought
he was insane
his by the way the jailers let out a big
cheer when he had his first movement as
they said but anyway because that there
one is insanity defense right right at
the window anyway
did I say out the window I don't know
what anyway so Lewis Powell you know if
you go into the the authorities of the
day you're gonna write about a trial it
seems to me you ought to to bone up on
the the same books read the same books
and authorities that the lawyers read so
you know what they're arguing about and
I've never seen that anywhere so I kind
of look for a little clues in the
transcripts and they talk about this or
that authority and I went out and read
those things cover to cover and they're
they're fascinating because the law is
so vastly different in 1865 from way it
is now and in many ways it's the
opposite I mean there were times before
that and they would not accept the
guilty plea because they wanted you to
come out with the whole story they
wanted to give you a trial plea
bargaining was illegal and very very
important to this story
confessions of a conspirator could not
be used in court and that's important
for results I'll tell you in just a
moment but in any rate one of the things
I had to read in preparation for this
was a book by dr. Isaac Ray who was the
leading authority on medical
jurisprudence of insanity and I I
learned some fascinating things for
example any doctor surgeon
physician anybody with it with a medical
degree was considered legally qualified
to testify about somebody's sanity and
strange as it sounds some of these
people did get on the stand and
basically said well I don't really know
anything about it you know I remember
reading a book 20 years ago and I went
to medical school so okay well you
talked to the guy for about five minutes
what do you think about his sanity
well he's not not insane and that would
stand
and then they say do you even believe in
insanity no not really but that would
stand strange as it sounds to us and the
issue of insanity because one thing
always leads me to another the issue of
insanity was important to me because
Lewis Powell is very fascinating figure
an enigmatic person who behaves so
strangely I had to wonder was he really
insane or not his lawyer tried to say he
was but his lawyer wanted to put it off
to the last minute all the insanity
testimony because he had a real ringer
working for him Charles Nichols was the
head of st. Elizabeth's asylum well
that's now called st. Elizabeth but it
was the government asylum for the
criminally insane and Charles Nichols
was ready to testify that there is such
a thing as moral insanity and this man
has definitely got the problems that
would have left his his case on kind of
an upbeat for the defense point of view
however in waiting just a little too
long defense attorney William Doster
shot himself in the foot because dr.
Nichols had a sick wife named Ellen and
on the day that dr. Nichols was supposed
to appear Ellen died and dr. Nichols
said well you know I've got to go he did
not testify for Powell at that time and
and as a result they said okay
everything else is wrapped up you saved
this for the end what are we gonna do
now they said would you be willing
asking the defense would you be willing
to let some other doctors examine the
patient or the the prisoner yeah sure go
ahead legally I mean that's that was the
only answer he could give and and so a
whole team of government doctors walked
in and they examined the prisoner for
you know
or so and they all came out one after
another after another saying no he's not
insane he's just stupid and so there
went the defense so now William Doster
the defense attorney is left with no
insanity and he goes to give his
summation and he says I think it was
about June 20th or so he says okay so
he's not insane
but look at it this way
he's on his side we're on our side he's
on his he's been raised in this in this
environment where he thinks that what
he's doing is a good thing so to his own
people he's a hero and he starts playing
Powell up like some sort of a martyr and
then he closes out saying you know and
and consider this you know the death
penalty is so harsh for somebody who
after all hasn't killed anybody
William Seward the Secretary survived
his wounds his son Frederick survived
his wounds his other son Augustus
survived his wounds and all the bloody
mess that he left in that house and the
carnage and the and the the night of
horror that he visited upon that family
after all it wasn't fatal to anyone and
that's the note that William Doster left
with that group of of military officers
and that day while he while Doster was
giving that little speech that day
Frances Seward the mother of those two
men who were brutally injured and the
wife of secretary Seward died of a heart
attack
and of course everybody said well what
do you think after after seeing what she
saw of course this is what happened so
the deaths of two women
Ellen Nichols and Frances Seward played
a big part I think in the fate of Lewis
Powell
not that I'm saying in any way or mean
to imply that Powell would have been off
the hook let's face it this was a
hanging jury and when you look again at
the record you see
some of the very strange things that
have have completely new relevance for
us today we're talking now about these
military tribunals and this was a
military tribunal consider what happened
the last time and that is that they made
their own rules they can't quite do that
so much today but they made their own
rules in 1865 and they changed them
after the fact and Edmund Spangler the
stagehand who had really just been
helping booth out they decided that he
knew nothing about the plot but they
went ahead and convicted him anyway of
aiding and embedding in booths escape by
having somebody hold booths horse so
that booth could come out later
interestingly that's not what he was
charged with so he was found guilty of
something that had never been charged in
the first place that was one of the
rules they could bend and twist it at
will another one was that even though
they published their their rules in the
beginning they made up a new one when
they went into deliberations and by the
way in Military Commissions during the
Civil War the prosecutors were allowed
to come in and help them deliberate and
and during the deliberations some of
them found out probably what they did
not know beforehand certainly Lew
Wallace the only lawyer on the panel did
not know this they found out that this
was not a unanimous verdict didn't have
to be they had changed this so we're a
simple majority of five people could
convict but you couldn't get the death
penalty unless you had two-thirds
majority and so what you ended up with
was four people who were convicted on
six or more votes who got the death
penalty automatically they didn't like
the fact that they were hanging a woman
so five of this six or more who voted
guilt for Mary Surratt filed a petition
saying we think you shouldn't give her
the death penalty but at any rate those
people the four who were hanged in July
they got six or more votes the others
got five votes one vote in either
direction and the fate of each of those
people could have been so vastly
different it could have been an outright
acquittal on one side or the death
penalty on the other that's sort of a
razor-thin margin at any rate as I said
I would explain a little bit about the
confessions because there were very
stringent laws in 1865 that a person
could not plea bargain and could not his
his testimony could not be used in court
if he was considered a conspirator John
Wilkes Booth who knew this like
everybody else knew it at the time it
was certainly nothing novel about it he
was able to take people he didn't trust
sometimes they were conspirators
sometimes they weren't they were people
he you know he thought might discover
all this he could take those people and
build a nice little frame around them so
that they would look very guilty they
would look like they were a part of this
and legally and morally the prosecutors
would have to file charges against them
which completely kept their testimony
out of court it was very clever because
booth reminded people one after another
he said you can't implicate me because I
can implicate you and that's how that's
how at least in my mind I resolve what
for me was the most important question
of this case and that is how on earth
did booth keep this quiet
in the most paranoid period of American
history how did he get away with it
basically and we see all of these people
one after another telling authorities
afterward booth said I couldn't tell you
booth said I couldn't run away booth
said I couldn't do this because he
ticked off this list of evidence against
me and that was the cunning manipulator
that John Wilkes Booth was that's how he
was able to succeed getting as far as he
did into President Lincoln's box
to shoot him at the end of the war any
questions
the diary kept by Weichmann Louis
Weichmann was a other questions what was
the impact of a diary kept by Whiteman
I'm not aware of a diary kept by
Waichman but the the the journal that
that you have perhaps read was the
memoirs that he began later on after all
of this was published in 1975 by Floyd
Griswold and it had no real effect on
this except it was Whiteman's attempt to
you know explain himself like all
autobiographies in a sense it does have
that self-serving purpose Whiteman is
for me a very central character in all
this as I said John Wilkes Booth was was
trying to frame people and Louis
Weichmann became the government's star
witness in this case in spite of an
enormous number of pieces of evidence
against him and the reason the
government tipped the balance in
Whiteman's favor was well in part
because without his testimony they would
have very little but in part also they
felt they were on fairly safe ground one
of the things that they were never
allowed to bring in court because it
wasn't legal evidence was a letter that
whiteman had received in March of 65 in
which a Catholic priest
JB menu' who had once been white men's
mentor and confessor and a person he he
trusted a good deal he wrote to
Weichmann and he said I hastened to
answer your letter of yesterday it is so
mysterious and you know I'm paraphrasing
he says I really I'm troubled by this
because you say mrs. Surratt is a rebel
she's up to no good and all this sort of
thing and it troubles you and all but
you know there should be no secrets
between us what exactly you know why
don't you just come out with it now
waichman evidently the day before had
written a letter to his priests saying
that he was troubled by what was going
on in Surratt house he wanted to
unburden himself and the strange thing
is the priest
wrote this letter back to him kind of is
the only source for this information
Reichman himself never told anybody that
he tried to rat out the conspirators he
wanted to keep it quiet he was scared to
death and he never knew about this
letter in response from the priest the
reason is it was mailed to him in March
and it was received at the Surratt
boarding house to which it was addressed
because Weichmann lived there and
somebody at the Surratt boarding house
intercepted it and when the letter did
turn up in government hands it was in
the trunk of John Wilkes Booth and John
Wilkes Booth you know had somebody in
the Surratt house intercepting
Whiteman's mail and he knew that
Weichmann couldn't be trusted and from
that point on about the 20th of March
when by the way John Surratt was not in
town so we're talking about Mary Surratt
here from that point on everything that
the conspirators did they involved Lou
Weichmann
in it John Wilkes Booth sent a telegram
to Whiteman tell John to Telegraph the
number and Street at once
well Waichman had no idea what that was
about
you know John lives in the same house
and the telegram to him but no Weichmann
just took it and says hmm I don't know
what this means but this was delivered
to him at work in a government office
building and he's waving it around see I
told you I know this famous actor now
he's got all these witnesses okay
he's implicating himself and this was
the the clever way that booth
manipulated people got got this huge
case built against waichman they never
did anything without involving Waichman
and years later when John Surratt had
been let go after a hung jury in his own
trial he was he was tried separately he
was caught in in Egypt and I want to do
that escape route tour one of these days
I'll tell you
anyway the after john surratt trial he
went out on the lecture circuit and
somebody asked him he said was Lou
Weichmann a conspirator because he sure
looks like one and after Whiteman's
testimony had helped hang Mary Surratt
you would think that John Surratt who
has a flaming hatred for white men at
this point feels that he has betrayed
him and the family he could have he
could have burned white men there's no
statute of limitations on on this and
his answer was very interesting he said
basically and again I'm paraphrasing no
he wasn't man enough to be one of us in
the back the question is did I find any
connection between the Dahlgren raid in
1864 and the Lincoln conspiracy
well the Dogman raid was which was
broken up in early march 64 was supposed
to have involved perhaps killing
Jefferson Davis and his cabinet and and
burning and sacking the city of Richmond
supposedly Lincoln may have ordered the
this to be done and the story goes that
sometimes a great many people have over
the years believed that the
assassination of Lincoln was ordered in
retaliation for that my feeling is that
since there's never been any kind of a
direct connection there's never been any
mention of it by booth or anyone
connected to this
I just couldn't couldn't make that
connection on my own and also it's it's
kind of strange that a person would wait
thirteen months to retaliate I would
expect a direct retaliation to come
within a few weeks or you know something
along those lines so no I never found
anything I hope that's enough of an
answer to join the Confederate Army and
also was there any effort to conscripted
him into the Union
ah good questions the questions were why
had not booth gone south to join the
Confederate Army and was there any
effort to conscription into the Union
Army take the second part of that first
John Wilkes Booth avoided the draft by
not having a permanent address he was
officially a resident of Philadelphia
where he had lived during the 1860
census his mother had moved up to New
York City with his brother Edwin and
that kind of made him a resident of New
York when they filed his estate papers
later on they said John Wilkes Booth a
resident of New York but the draft was
handled locally by Provost Marshal's who
who would go out basically knocking on
doors going through going through census
returns and city directories and things
like that finding all these men and and
basically hauling them in if a person
wasn't there he wasn't reachable and I
was one of the one of the many loopholes
in the in the whole draft process during
the war but I never heard that they
tried to draft him but as an actor he
moved around from place to place and I
don't think anybody could quite get a
hand on him and say you're you know
you're gonna serve in Missouri troops or
something like that because he happened
to be in st. Louis he'd say no I don't
live here I'm going back home right now
and and then he would go to some other
City and the same thing might happen
there so that's how he avoided the draft
he did not go into Confederate service
there is some indication within the
family that that he did genuinely
promise his mother for this heartfelt
promise that he would not join the cause
and that he would stay out of the fight
for her sake he and his brother Edwin
got into some real knock-down drag-out
fights about politics and toward the end
there Edwin was sort of taunting him a
little bit you feel so strongly about it
why didn't you join up why didn't you
actually do something and I can't help
but believe that that may have preyed on
his conscience a little bitty saying
okay my chances is now my chance is now
fading away
the war is about over and I haven't done
anything I just I just can't live with
that and that was one of the things that
gave him this little bit of sense of
urgency about killing the president when
there was clearly not much point in it
anymore
yes question is did I ever get a chance
to meet Jim Bishop yes I did and he told
me one time that he made a huge fortune
on the book and that he he always got a
lot of mail because of it that it was
the one thing more than anything else
that really kind of formed his identity
as a writer all the other things he had
done I mean most of us probably you know
don't know the other the the extent to
which his writing career had stretched
in all directions but he said that was
that was the one crowning moment for him
oh I'm sorry
right behind you jack did you find
anything adverse to dr. Mudd did I find
anything adverse to dr. Mudd yeah it's a
good question and it's that the answer
would be a few more hours but what I
found that was adverse to dr. Mudd was
all the usual stuff that the prosecutor
put forth but I also found that dr. Mudd
and Booth never trusted each other from
day one and that's the reason we find so
much adverse to dr. Mudd because these
things that that counted against him at
the trial were not things that Mudd had
done but were rather things that Booth
had done to him and that made all the
difference to me that and the fact that
when John Wilkes Booth is at dr. Mudds
house in the day after the assassination
dr. Mudd
got up and went shopping in town and
he's taking this leisurely trip into
bryan town and he buys some you know
matches and calico and nails and
whatever and he goes back at a walking
pace back to his house four miles away
and he stops to talk to some neighbors
and they're talking about the
assassination and the price of lumber
and and at some point a couple of
neighbors gather together and one of
them
you know who do you think did this and I
do have documentary evidence that the
man who was in charge of the federal
troops had had just gone into that town
at about the same time had learned or so
he believed that a man named John Boyle
had committed the assassination and he
had been telling everybody we're looking
for Boyle all of these people including
dr. MA knew Boyle so they had been in
some ways misled but there are other
stories going out there and in the
course of this conversation Mudd and
some others say well you know I heard it
was Boyle and somebody else says no I
heard it was booth and then dr. Mudd
says well there were a couple of booths
they were all actors aren't they and and
one of them said well is it that one
that was around here last year nosing
around and at that point dr. Mudd was a
you know yeah I'd better go home and to
my way of thinking and there's always
room for argument about everything but
you know what to my way of thinking
nobody who knows the most wanted
fugitive in America is in his house is
going to leave his wife and four young
children alone with him he may have even
trusted booth but hey how does he know
that the cavalry isn't going to come
surrounding the house and just shooting
up the place
so no I I I think that was the moment
during that conversation on the
afternoon of April 15 that dr. Mudd
first realized who that was and what he
had done he may have said this guy looks
vaguely familiar but but I really don't
think that that that Mudd was guilty as
charged and left with his sister in
Philadelphia
there okay before the assassination John
Wilkes Booth had written a couple of
letters and it left him with his sister
in Philadelphia one of them was
addressed to whom it may concern and it
was a long sort of manifesto about about
why he was going to make a prisoner of
this man Abraham Lincoln as some of you
may know the original purpose of the
conspiracy or so booth said was to
capture Lincoln and to force the Union
government to resume an exchange policy
prisoner of war exchange and and so he
said you know this is the reasons we're
going to and then he goes on about you
know how the workers in the north are
treated worse than slaves in the south
and you know on and on and on with all
this stuff like everybody else who
defend slavery he's got the blinders on
but he's he's saying nothing
particularly different from the usual
defenses of southern rights and all that
business but any rate he also wrote a
letter to his mother dearest beloved
mother you know I know that you know my
act is going to do to you and and I'm
sorry about that but these two letters
and some other things were in there as
well it's interesting to me again
because the kind of the the big theme of
my book is how booth manipulated people
there were also some things in there
that I believe were addressed to Samuel
Knapp Chester Chester was a person booth
had tried to get involved in the plot
and he recoiled that the idea was
horrified and Booth pretended in fact
running around telling other people that
Chester had in effect signed on he even
took some letters and things with
Chester's name on them letters that
Chester had sent to him about the plot
kind of begging him not to do it and he
put those in there as well so that if he
decided to do something Chester could be
implicated also and in this plot as it
happened booths sister Asia had known
Chester all her life and she she
remembered those letters down in the
safe and she went down there and she
destroyed certain things before she told
anybody else that there was anything
there
was there simply no connection or do
they not try hard enough and in some
accounts I wish I could give an
authoritative source a Robert Lincoln
Stewart Lee before his death in 1927
burned documents that he claimed proved
the treason of a number of Lincoln's
cabinet have you ever been able to track
that one down as the question is about
Robert Todd Lincoln who just before his
death claimed to have destroyed
documents that would have implicated a
member of his father's own cabinet I've
heard that story many times but like so
many others I couldn't trace it to its
original source I wanted to find a
transcript of an interview with Robert
or a letter from Robert or something
like that
and if I can't find that I kind of take
it and put it in the urban legend file I
you know I've heard it many times but I
don't know and it it may be that it's
true but I I can't go there you asked at
first wouldn't it been a remarkable coup
on the part of the federal prosecutors
if they had proved the Confederate
Secret Service was in on this believe me
they tried and they failed in part
because they they either believed the
wrong people or they you know they sort
of with a wink and a nod let the wrong
people in and those people were exposed
in fact there's a new book out about one
of the people the chief perjurer in this
case a man named Charles Dunham who was
posing as Sanford Conover and claiming
that you know he knew a lot of things
about all this that tied the Confederate
government in Conover and several other
witnesses were later proved to have
perjured themselves and Conover was sort
of the ringleader who told everybody
exactly what they would have to say in
order to make all their stories mesh
once that fell apart the federal
government had a lot of trouble finding
anything else of substance that would
make either a commission or a jury or
even the general public believe that
there was as hard and fast connection
Oh laughs last question what are being
evicted venture Saran his estate Elmyra
then eventually he ended up in Rome as a
Swiss Guard and then of course to Egypt
but what I don't understand is that to
be out the movers mr. Briscoe and I had
to beat at which he was and had to be at
least five eight which he was but you
also had to be a Swiss citizen okay
there's a the question is when John
Surratt was on his escape at one point
he joined the Swiss Guards it is
actually the papal Zouaves the the
requirements that jack alleges were and
I don't know anything about the
requirements but Surratt did not meet
all of them one of which was that you
had to be a citizen the papal Zouaves at
the time I understand were a bit like
the Foreign Legion in a sense that a lot
of the people who come into the story
were in fact Americans and in what is
now Italy there were a number of little
Wars going on and all of the different
kingdoms were then consolidating and
Victor Emmanuel was becoming the first
king of Italy and you know it was at
this one point where they were just
about to crush the Pope and kill him and
and you know take over the the papal
States as well and John Surratt kind of
jumped into the middle of that because
they were taking mercenaries and he he
you know had had once studied in a
Catholic College and knew how to get by
and in French and other languages and
you know he he could certainly get along
just fine in fact of the presence of
another American their Canadian actually
is eventually what undid Surratt and led
to his eventual capture well it's like
the old days I'm being evicted again
sometimes apartment like you did said
did you exhausted searching for
something like the hotel or something
before the age of modern computers or
you know indexing how do you do that the
question is some authors claim that
they've exhausted all the all the
possibilities and have kind of gone down
that that last dead-end and not found
anything there are a lot of lincoln
books out there and when you when you
sort of come to a dead end you don't
know where to keep you know where to
look any further you never know where
something is gonna pop up I was in the
New York Public Library one day and and
I had the habit of going through the
manuscript division and going through
the the card files and just looking you
know from A to Z and seeing what's in
there and if any names would pop into my
you know into my head as I go along
there was one the Howard shorthand
collection and I happened to realize
that the man who who transcribed the
testimony of the trial was a brother of
the inventor of shorthand that sort of
led me to think hey maybe there's
something in here about the Pitman
family and sure enough there was the
only known original photograph of Mary
Surratt was in this collection
you know copied from one in the
possession of Ben Pitman who's in whose
brother Isaac invented Pitman shorthand
and so on so you never you never know
where it's going to come up you just you
can't count on just doing it in a
purposeful way you just have to kind of
put your cast a wide net and hope some